THAT.
>> Tucker: WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW THE STORY.
CHARLES AND DAVID KOCH OR TWO OF
THE RICHEST MEN IN THE WORLD
APPEAR TO SOME OF THE MONEY IS
INHERITED, MUCH OF IT THEY MADE
THEMSELVES.
BUT TO THEIR CREDIT THE KOCHS
ARE NOT CONTENT TO GET RICHER,
THEY HAVE A SINCERE DESIRE TO
CHANGE THE WORLD.
THE BROTHERS HAVE BEEN THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT FUNDERS OF
REPUBLICAN POLITICS IN
WASHINGTON.
THE KOCH NETWORK SPENDS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, EVERY
CONSERVATIVE TAKES KOCH MONEY.
MANY REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS OWE
THEIR CAREERS TO THE KOCHS AND
ARE HAPPY TO SAY SO.
FOR PEOPLE WHOSE MAIN BUSINESS
IS MAKING FERTILIZER AND PAPER
TOWELS, THE KOCHS HAVE BEEN
REMARKABLY EFFECTIVE IN AMERICAN
POLITICS, NOT SURPRISINGLY THE
LEFT HATES THEM FOR IT.
BOTH THE KOCH BROTHERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO BY THE WAY ARE VERY
NICE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
GROTESQUELY AND REPEATEDLY
MALIGNED BY THE MEDIA, THIS HAS
CONVINCED MANY CONSERVATIVES
THAT THE KOCHS MUST BE ON THEIR
SIDE, ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN
SLANDERED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS GOT TO
BE DOING SOMETHING RIGHT, THAT'S
THE IDEA.
IT'S NOT A BAD STANDARD BUT IN
THIS CASE, IN THE CASE OF THE
KOCHS, CONSERVATIVES MIGHT WANT
TO PAUSE AND RETHINK THE
RELATIONSHIP.
AS IT TURNED OUT, KOCHS DON'T
HAVE MUCH IN COMMON WITH
CONSERVATIVES, THEY ARE TOTALLY
OPPOSED TO MOST CONSERVATIVE
POLICY GOALS.
THE KOCHS ARE LIBERTARIAN
IDEOLOGUES, PASSIONATE AND
INFLEXIBLE IN WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
AMERICA FIRST?
THEY FIND THE NOTION ABSURD, AND
ECONOMIC POLICY THAT SEEKS TO
STRENGTHEN FAMILIES, THE KOCHS
ANNOUNCED THAT AS CRONY
CAPITALISM AND PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS, THEY WILL TELL YOU
SO.
CONTROLLING OUR BORDERS, THEY
CONSIDER THAT RACIST.
BERNIE SANDERS NOTED THAT THE
KOCH BROTHERS ARE FAR TO THE
LEFT OF HIM ON IMMIGRATION.
OPEN BORDERS?
THAT'S EIGHT KOCH BROTHERS
PROPOSAL.
IT'S WHAT WE HAVE NOW AND THAT'S
THANKS IN PART TO THE KOCHS.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS WANT A SECURE BORDER
AND LESS IMMIGRATION, THAT'S WHY
THEY VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
TWO AND A HALF YEARS LATER, THE
BORDER IS MORE POROUS THAN EVER,
A TIDE OF HUMANITY'S FLOOD AGAIN
ILLEGALLY.
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS HAVE
DONE ALMOST NOTHING TO HELP,
WHY?
YOU CAN THANK THE KOCHS FOR
THAT.
IN 2018, KOCH BACKED
ORGANIZATIONS FREEDOM NETWORK
AND NETWORK FOR PROSPERITY, PAST
AND THE C4 SO-CALLED DREAMERS.
IF AMNESTY REMAINS THE KOCHS TOP
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY.
IF YOU'RE WONDERING WHY THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY OFTEN SEEMS OUT
OF SYNC WITH ITS OWN VOTERS,
THIS IS WHY.
IT'S NOT JUST ON IMMIGRATION.
THE KOCH NETWORK HAS PUSHED
REPUBLICANS TO JOIN THE LEFT AND
GOING SOFT ON CRIME, THE KOCHS
BACK THE FIRST STEP ACT WHICH IS
ALLOWING DRUG TRAFFICKERS TO
LEAVE PRISON EARLY.
THEY SUPPORT THE SENTENCING
REFORM AND CORRECTIONS ACT WHICH
WOULD CUT REQUIRED PENALTIES FOR
HEROIN AND COCAINE TRAFFICKERS
IN HALF.
THEY ARE DOING ALL OF THIS IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DEADLIEST DRUG
EPIDEMIC IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE KOCHS DON'T BOTHER TO ARGUE
THESE SO-CALLED REFORMS WOULD
HELP ANY LAW-ABIDING AMERICAN IN
ANY WAY, THEY JUST BELIEVE IT'S
THE RIGHT THING, THE LIBERTARIAN
THING TO DO.
SO THEY ARE PUSHING FOR IT.
ON ECONOMICS, YOU WON'T BE
SURPRISED TO LEARN THE KOCHS
VIEWS BEAR NO RESEMBLANCE AT ALL
TO WHAT REPUBLICAN VOTERS
BELIEVE.
THEY PUSH FOR EXPANDING
MEDICARE, BEST MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS ARE OPPOSED TO THAT.
MOST EVERYONE ELSE, REPUBLICANS
WANT LOWER DRUG PRICES AND YET
THE KOCHS ARE WORKING TO KILL A
BILL THAT WOULD PREVENT DRUG
COMPANIES FROM CHARGING
AMERICANS MORE THAN THEY CHARGE
THE PEOPLE OF CANADA OR FRANCE,
THAT SEEMS LIKE A FAIR IDEA TO
MOST PEOPLE.
KOCHS ARE PREVENTING IT FROM
HAPPENING.
THEN THEY HELPED DRAFT THE 2017
TAX CUTS, THAT TURNED OUT TO BE
A FAR BETTER DEAL FOR CORPORATE
AMERICA.
A MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS
SUPPORT CAPPING INTEREST RATES
ON CREDIT CARDS AND PAYDAY
LOANS, THE KOCHS THINK THAT'S
RIDICULOUS.
WHEN DAVID KOCH RAN FOR
VICE PRESIDENT, ABOLISHING USURY
LAWS WAS PART OF HIS PLATFORM.
IT'S WHAT MANY RICH LIBERALS
BELIEVE BUT NOT WHAT MOST
REPUBLICANS BELIEVE.
GIVEN THAT THE KOCHS OF THE
SINGLE MOST POWERFUL FIGURES IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IF THEY DON'T SEEM INTERESTED IN
HEARING DO THAT, THEY HAVE NO
JOIN TO A LEFT-WING CAMPAIGN
AGAINST FREE SPEECH IN AMERICA.
NEXT MONTH THE CHARLES KOCH
INSTITUTE WILL HOLD A SUMMIT
WITH EXECUTIVES FROM AIRBNB,
PATRON, MOZILLA, THE STATE IS TO
FORMULATE BEST PRACTICES ON THE
FIGHT AGAINST HATE ONLINE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS,
IT MEANS CENSORSHIP OF YOUR
VIEWS.
FOR THE LEFT, FIGHTING EXTREMISM
ALWAYS MEANS CRUSHING NORMAL
CONSERVATIVES.
IT'S WHITE PATRIOT ON BAND MODEL
YOU NOVELIST.
BAND MILO.
KOCHS DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT,
MORE TO THE POINT, THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT REPUBLICAN VOTERS OR
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM.